so gary is really just sort of the
latest in a long line of filmmakers that
you sort of helped prop up and you know
really help them launch into their own
directing careers I'm curious what is it
you see in filmmakers that makes you
excited to take that journey with them
and specifically what was that you saw
in Gary well the thing that I looked out
for the most literally is are you guys a
fan of the genre and and and you know
those are usually the kind of people
that I don't want to work with you know
like they they understand it they get it
they they they love the whoa and so it
just makes it easier for me to sort of
work with them and it makes it easy for
me to communicate with them because
we're gonna have a shorthand language
and but the fact we've Gary is you know
is the fact that we've worked together a
whole bunch of other movies before that
he has written and produced for for us
and and it felt like it was like the
next natural progression for Gary to to
step behind the camera and and he's
actually been harboring the aspiration
to direct for a very long time now and
you know I could I see him you know
sometimes quietly in the background of
other projects where you would serve
literally take notes directing notes and
paying a lot of attention and just
learning and just sort of soaking it up
and I really think a lot of that paid
off because I think he did such a
terrific job with Annabel comes home
yeah it's really really fun film yeah it
kind of has like to make a parallel to
another franchise you've been a part of
like a Fast Five energy brings the whole
gang together for this really fun
popcorn experience can you talk about
sort of helping land that energy and
what the development was like to get
there because it's it's different from
the tone of the conjuring films yeah
it's different from the other Annabel
yeah and in some ways but it still feels
like it's part of the country sort of
well because a the most obvious
connection is the fact that variant
Patrica in this one and and as the title
would suggest Annabel comes home which
the other two
went at home yeah and so this one you
know the fact that this one now takes
place in the Warrens home and for a lot
of fans and audiences out there they
they were first introduced to NFL from
the first conjuring film where you know
they saw Annabelle in the haunted
artifact and and so it's great to
finally sort of come full circle and be
able to bring the story back to the
warrens home and and by the very nature
that that the cast in this film is much
younger you know the younger goes and
and the younger boys and all that in
this film it kind of took on a more
Emblem tone it has very 80s quality
about it and that's something that Gary
and I love and so we're just lean into
that and just sort of embrace the fact
that you know that this is still a scary
movie in the country universe but not be
afraid to just have fun with it
yeah and it is really fun I think summer
is a great spot for it I'm you obviously
are always spinning
many plates and so coming out of Aquaman
you guys have announced that the trench
is happening which I find so exciting so
many monsters opportunities but I'm also
curious what did you learn from building
the conjuring universe that you're able
to apply there because it seems sort of
that that's falling in line with the
general start in the home base and build
out from it yeah I I think it's
important to make sure you get the first
movie right first so to set the world
set the characters and then and then if
that works then you can organically spin
off all these different stories how you
think the keys to kind of create a wall
that that is that is rich and creeks
characters that people like and care
about and then then it just makes this
sort of you know the branching yeah that
much easier at least more organic and
and I think that's what I learned from
you know sort of helping design the
conjuring whoa is just you know
realizing that that realizing how to
build the wall built characters and then
and then let it organically take you
where you where it wants to go as
opposed to you telling it way it should
go yeah well I say the more shared
horror universes the better so thank
things are doing the Lord's work